vende banderas en esta calle beirut para
los fanáticos del fútbol reconoce que
las ventas son escasas
este mundial es muy extraño porque la
gente tiene menos dinero y todos muy
caro la gente no tiene dinero para
comprar comida Entonces por qué
comprarían banderas
se sienten la crisis económica en su
cotidianidad con un salario mínimo
equivalente a 20 dólares y una inflación
galopante alrededor del 80% de la
población ha caído en la pobreza el
dinero no alcanza para satisfacer las
necesidades básicas Mohamed dager
propietario de este café es consciente
de ello debe cobrar la entrada del café
a los aficionados para ver los partidos
del Mundial Batman ahora debemos cobrar
un mínimo de 5 dólares por sillas sin
incluir ningún pedido porque tenemos que
pagar entre 3.000 y 4.000 dólares por la
suscripción a los partidos del Mundial
en copas del mundo anterior es la
transmisión de los partidos era gratuita
a través de la televisión estatal pero
ahora los cafés y bares que difunden el
evento deportivo deben pagar y por lo
tanto los fanáticos del fútbol también
algunos deciden Simplemente no ver los
partidos porque prefieren invertir ese
dinero en sus hogares Sin embargo a
pesar de la crisis este hombre no
renuncia a la fiebre futbolera
nos encanta Vivir la vibra del mundial
porque nos hace felices y nos da la
oportunidad de salir de la depresión que
estamos viviendo debido a los problemas
de agua electricidad y económicos en
general
una Euforia pasajera en un país que vive
una de las peores crisis económicas que
el mundo haya tenido registro desde hace
más de 150 años según el Banco Mundial